yo Nick you got that uh sea views video
going up soon so I could write a rapper
oh yeah yeah yeah just give me give me
second place before tonight right now yo
are those my mice uh yeah man um I'm
actually using this one to shoot and
this one to build so yeah give me back
to you later
can you just ask next time for use my
stuff oh for sure sar dog the hell hey J
is that the keyboard I was off my desk
oh yeah is that cool I just like to have
both when I played pub G hey Michael
while you're here a busy day today for
me it was swamped
I was multitasking we're using your I'll
give them back to you in like an hour I
think I said I was talking give me a
second thank you
[Music]
so the thought occurred to me yesterday
I was watching you play four at night
you're playing right now is watching you
play Pub gee if I'm working at pub G
Corp or blue hole or fir player unknown
and I'm working at pub G for night
success it's not a good sign it might be
scaring me you know like the derogatory
thing to say about pub G is that it's
just a game mode it's more than that
it's got great math design and like the
very premise of it it's fantastic but
that's what it is almost it's like a
premise whereas like you see something
like fortnight doing it's so great
parenting that like sub genre almost you
have to like think the people at pubs
you're saying well now a bunch of other
games can do it battlefield fives coming
out this year you know you have black
ops for you have like even like someone
mentioned like possibility of Red Dead I
don't think they're gonna do it with Red
Dead but like I don't make games right
it must be really easy to put this mode
into your game and siphon even more
players from pop G I imagine and that
might be scary the people at funky right
now yeah I think if your pub G you have
to be a little worried but I also think
if you're fortnight you also have to be
a little bit worried as well because
this formula although I guess you could
say fortnight has kind of refined it and
given it its own twist by creating the
building aspects of the game but while
keeping the Battle Royale style there's
a lot to be said about some of the other
triple-a titles that could go down that
battle royale mode one of the
limitations of you know having a battle
royale game is that the foundation the
game engine like has to work on a large
scale I know like we keep bringing a
battlefield that's because they've done
like 64 players like I know some servers
or mods and previous battlefield games
can hold up to 128 players so if it if
it doesn't break at that point then you
have the foundation to work with to
implement like a battle royale style
game and you look at a fortnight which I
mean when that first came out for
tonight saved the world I would have
never thought a battle royale mode could
fit into that game I don't know I'm sure
they were working out longer but it
seemed like within weeks all of a sudden
they had a developer update and
next thing you know now yeah now how big
is it so many of you we know we want to
communicate with you we know you want
the communication we know you expect
that's the crazy thing yeah for tonight
is the last thing I thought that this
like you said that like formula would
fit into but also you look at pub G and
I mean I love the game and like to be
clear I'm not saying you can't play both
of these we all do and love both of them
especially pub G myself personally but
my point being that it could siphon more
people away from pub G puppy has not
been that great about updating the game
they're doing it weekly and stuff but
there's still always something that I
feel like it's still very broken or
janky the game since the beginning has
been janky it's felt like that
endearingly clunky game mode that I
loved playing oh god what is this chat
I guess we're fighting our way out of
this right oh so like when if
battlefield 5 comes along and dice with
its track history with its frostbite
engine it starts like knocking out of
the park with a hundred player under 28
player battle royale mode what is my
incentive to go back to pub G which I
know is still at that point might be
fairly rough around the edges to fill in
that void though it would probably be a
game that's a little bit more on the
realistic side but can also be
accessible in a way I know for you
always bring up that fortnight is widely
successful because it's free so I'm
still unsure as to whether or not like a
full priced triple-a game came kind of
syphon pub G's crowd also you need to
remember there's like different ways
players play these games
whereas I find that if when I'm playing
pub G it's more methodical it's slow I'm
trying to navigate the map and the
circles in order to like put myself in a
position to win
versus the fortnight
I really do feel like rushing other
players building quickly is more like
that pace more style for fortnight and
so there'll be different kind of ways
that people play these games that'll
separate it but yeah I do totally agree
that pub she needs to confine some
updates whether it's new maps different
styles of like modes and things like
that the thing people are saying what
pub G first came out that it's just in
game mode almost holds more weight now
like it was oddly cement as an insult to
people who were going crazy about I love
the game we play a lot but it's crazy
because you're thinking of tactical
shooters and you're looking at games
that are blowing up recently and I don't
want to like say that Rainbow six siege
should do some sort of mode like this
they don't they're not gonna have enough
people but like it's 5v5 there's no
respawns who's just saying Ubisoft
couldn't increase it to like 66 and then
its last person standing on a smaller
map right like they just introduced
zombies today an operation outbreak also
I think it's becoming less frowned upon
to like copy the genre now remember one
fortnight first did it people are like
oh it's just a clone this cheap I feel
like at first I got a lot of bad press
but now it's like oh it has 15 million
more people than puppy maybe if I'm at
dice if I'm a tray are to find that
Ubisoft I'm probably thinking to myself
or I'm gonna bring out the idea that my
creative director or something maybe we
should try to do this for a limited time
and see how it works and then see how
many people we get
[Music]
what do you think pub G can do to
counter this you know hypothetical in
some ways I do that up in some ways
realistic like siphoning of players well
one of the biggest things which they've
already done is that pub G has two maps
which for most games that doesn't sound
like a lot but fortnight still has its
one map and just switching between the
two two completely different maps that
you get to play in and I think that adds
a lot and they have plans of adding more
free maps down the road and I think that
will bring a lot of people back every
single time nothing like that like when
you think about it that's very that's
like a kind of a PC outlook in it and I
also think about it for myself and
friends who play on xbox we still only
have one map for pub G on Xbox we're
still waiting for the desert map there's
still way for like a lot of optimization
things to be fixed on Xbox there's a lot
of things that need to be updated on
Xboxes vs. the PC version and I think
that also is something pub G needs to do
ASAP
especially with for tonight being on
console being on Xbox being on
PlayStation yeah so and pub G is not on
PlayStation yes is the which is the
biggest console available now there's
probably a huge amount of people who
would probably jump onto puppy if they
could but can't because it's not there
so then their next option is fortnight
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
with blue hole they open a new office in
Amsterdam right so now they have South
Korea Amsterdam pub D corpus part of
blue hole or something I'm hoping that
with increased numbers and hopefully
resources they can you know maintain the
Battle Royale arms race so to speak down
the road because obviously like it's
still got a ton of players it's still
one of those stream games it's not going
anywhere right now it's still my
preferred game but as far as for night
being kind of a bad omen for pub gee I
wonder if there will be like three more
games and we're talking about that are
taking players not just from pub G but
also from fortnight and it's becoming
this widely dispersed thing it's like it
is it's like a like a game mode that's
being kind of like slowly spread out
over a few games and I'm curious to see
if that just keeps becoming far-reaching
yeah things can look totally different
like two or three years from now we're
almost like Battle Royale almost comes
standard with multiplayer games and it's
like well there's nothing too special
about it now it's just like what you
come to expect I'm not saying that will
happen but I don't see it like I have
you know possible I have my fingers
crossed that it becomes a staple kind of
multiplayer mode just because of like
how fun I've seen it to be whether it's
pub G or fortnight but yeah oh this
thing it will die eventually I don't
think it'll last forever I Nona say it's
a fad because I think it's at the point
where it's kind of past that point of
just being a fad and I have a feeling
plenty of games will do this but I think
people will get sick of it after a while
I mean I'm 300 hours in pub G I still
love playing that games but man it does
not have the same draw that it used to
and for that same reason like I've only
played a little bit before tonight but
I'm not gonna spend much more time with
fortnight because it's like I had my
fill of the Battle Royale
yeah I mean the carry is just about what
the conversation will be in a year what
games he'll have jumped into this
sub-genre if you that's what you want to
call it and you know like where pop G is
at at that point because at this point I
think they start to need to think about
what they're gonna do our future maybe
use like brainstorm a few ideas a
persona battle royale was getting
[Music]